it happened for anthony lynn the
chargers coach
on monday and the vibe coming out of la
for the past several weeks has been we
respect anthony lynn
we're not going to make any decisions
we're not going to do anything we're not
going to start talking to people behind
his back we're going to let him get
through this season
and then we're gonna make a decision and
they got four straight wins as a result
of it
maybe in hindsight the four straight
wins don't really help them if we
consider the philadelphia dynamic which
we'll be talking about in an hour but
still they finish on a high note
they win four in a row and then they
promptly fire anthony lynn
it's not a surprise that they did it the
management of the games
was in question they have too much
talent to have been three and nine
the low point was the 45 to nothing loss
at home to the patriots
with five games left in the season and
you know it's a it's an attractive job
and this is a
an ideal time if you're ever going to
make a change early in a franchise
quarterback's career let's go ahead and
do it now
and let's put the the sign out in the
front yard making it clear that you've
got a very very very attractive position
for a head coach to choose to come to
and work with justin herbert so you know
you and i chris have been
ambivalent about this because we like
anthony lynn but
the chargers decided it was time and now
it's time and now
they have an opportunity to get a really
good head coach
to to continue to help justin herbert
improve
yeah i mean that that's the exciting
thing anthony lynn
you know there was some good things he
did there you know but
the last two years players you know gone
in the wrong direction even though there
was moments this year where you go
seems like they can play against anybody
and
and kind of hang in there you know uh
for the for the most part other than
that new england game like we talked
about
but the the biggest thing with anthony
lynn too last year
you know we saw some end of the game
disappointment right
philip rivers i certainly was part to
blame there
he went through a funk last year this
year we just saw
repetitive issues down the stretch of
games it was just
one thing or another it didn't matter
whether it was special teams
the offense running the ball at the
wrong time you know
improper usage of time timeouts all of
those things and
you know that's what came back to bite
them and never a good look biker
something
is off when you have a top 10 offense
and a number 11 defense in football and
you're really nowhere near the playoff
conversation that tells you something's
being done wrong but
like to your point i mean i don't know
i know like everybody wants trevor
lawrence isn't this the best job out
there
i think this is the best job out there
you got a guy that we
we know is on the way to superstardom at
quarterback
and there's other pieces there i would
think this is a job this is in
high demand as any that's that's
available this year in the nfl
i would always take the quarterback who
has shown he can do it over the one
right hasn't right because with the one
who hasn't you still
don't know until he does it with justin
herbert you know
what you're getting and you know what he
can do and you've got almost a full
season of film to look at
the problem with the charters in recent
years has been too many close games and
if you're going to be in that many close
games
you had better be bill belichick and
find a way
when the game is on the line to bend it
all in your favor
and anthony lynn couldn't do that enough
remember we've talked
multiple times about philip rivers
comment after the 2018 season when they
were 12 and four we could have been 16-0
or six
and 10. well that luck started going
against them
sharply in 2019 and 2020 and now anthony
lynn is out
if you're going to be a sustained
long-term coach
you can't just be skin of the teeth
victories you have to be winning some
games not all of them but you have to be
winning some games convincingly it can't
come down to the wire it can't be
a a key decision here or there made in
the moment especially if you're not
going to be making on a consistent
basis good to see the right decision
right that's the big
you're right they got in those close
games and did everything you said and
then it came down to key moments
and usually they found a way to mess it
up and you're right that's like a double
whammy there for a head coach and
you know sorry to see him go i really am
uh because i do like him like you said
but
yeah that's gonna be i i think that's i
think that's the
job to your point if you know we know
trevor lawrence yes
all awesome yes you know deshawn watson
with the houston texans
amazing that's certainly up there but
you think joey bosa derwin james
you know you know some of the the tight
end play hunter henry and of course him
and keenan
allen there's pieces there already to
play with to think you could turn that
team around in a hurry
and be in a major player with with a big
time big time quarterback
now whoever gets that job i think one of
the first things he needs to do when he
walks
through the door is commission some sort
of an internal study on
strength and conditioning training
flexibility what are they doing right or
wrong because they get too many guys
injured they do
that's been an issue with the chargers
and
until you really get into the nuts and
bolts of it and look at what you're
doing and why you're doing you know we
see guys every week get
twisted up into knots and they bounce up
and they're fine
these are our professional athletes
highly conditioned
very flexible and they escape injury
more often than not but with chargers
it's been
not and there's too many key players who
aren't available you mentioned derwin
james he didn't play at all this year
one of the best safeties in football
they didn't have the benefit of him at
all and you constantly have to worry
about joey bosa
what can they do better and to the
extent that your coach becomes kind of
the ceo and that's really the question
of what they're looking for what do they
want is this a guy who's going to be
subservient to tom telesco
are they looking for someone who can
take over the organization do they want
someone who's been around who's got
experience
as a head coach for almost a decade like
a jason garrett a lot of people were
surprised last night when his name
surfaced because
the book on him is close the book and
throw it away frankly as a head coach
but what do you think they should be
looking for by way of
type of coach to get the most out of not
just justin herbert but the rest of the
organization yeah sure
i mean well like mike first off i mean
you're right they got to figure out what
they want
i think like if they want to go that ceo
route
you know management type route that's
probably where jason garrett comes in to
talk there right that's that's right
that's where i would think that name
comes about
you know he's been a guy that you know i
know it didn't like blow us away in
dallas but hey dallas didn't look that
great this year without him they were
kind of a mess
maybe he was a little better than we
should give him you know gave him credit
for
but like the guy to me mike
without a doubt you got justin herbert
you got already a top 10 quarterback in
football
you got a guy that i think is one of the
five best arms and throwers and passers
in football
you go full andy reed patrick mahomes on
this
you go offensive head coach and get into
arms race with the rest of football and
say
we don't care if we're in the same
division with the chiefs and that's
where i go
brian dayball i love eric me enemy he
deserves a job
i'm just not a big fan of let's take a
guy from a team within our division
and try to copy what they do i don't
know i don't really know that formula
ever working
to me bringing a guy like dayball who
just worked with the young quarterback
and josh allen and we see the results
and then i mean you just you go after it
and you
you try to get you sign big time
receivers and everything like that you
try to become the biggest show in la
because you got a quarterback that can
make you the biggest show in la
yeah and i think you're right they need
somebody who's going to come in with
that energy and that vision and who is
an offensive guy
something that dawned on me yesterday
and i've thought of this in the past but
it really
crystallized as we were hearing rumors
that gary kubiak the vikings offensive
coordinator is contemplating and
planning to retire right the vikings
have had a revolving door at offensive
coordinator the past several years
i i and i know coach dungey would
disagree with me on this i'd never hire
a defensive coach not in this climate
because if you hire a defensive coach
and your team is successful you're
losing your offensive coordinator
if you hire an offensive coach and your
team is successful
maybe you keep your defensive
coordinator dennis allen's name never
comes up right and he's been a great
defensive coordinator for the saints
right do you think of the saints
as an offensive team and sean payton's
in charge
and dennis allen is just kind of like
what do i have to do to get considered
but but if you get a defensive guy and
you get a coordinator who works once
with justin herbert
see you later offensive coordinator now
you got to find another one
i mean it's it's you're right it's it's
uh certainly something you got to think
about you know
when you make that type of hire you got
to think two or three years down the
road a little bit to
what could happen what could happen to
the staff all those things
and you know to your point here we are
like
i mean again wink martindell is one of
the big best defensive minds in football
we don't really hear anything about him
robert sala again had a great year and i
know he's getting some interest but it
doesn't seem like the buzz is just like
you know out of control to where
you mean offensive is the way to go
right now it does seem that way it seems
to be the in
in vogue thing but especially when you
have a guy like justin herbert i think
that's that's where you just got to go
all right we have something special here
and we can we can win games strictly on
his right arm
and he has the type of talent to carry
the team
and if we put a system and a few players
around him
they could be one of the more fun teams
to watch in football which will bring
the fans in but of course we see you you
know you can win that way
and be very dangerous i'm going to give
back casey credit for putting this one
in my ear because i wouldn't have
thought of it but this is a good point
the the offensive coaches tend to
create the vibe of head coach in
training
defensive coordinators not across the
board sure i'm thinking of coach dungey
again because he was not this way at all
which may be one of the reasons why he
was an attractive head coaching
candidate
defensive coordinators are a little over
the top a little rough and tumble
rex ryan ish right you know you've got
robert saleh is the cheerleader on the
sidelines
you've got you've got you know that that
whole ryan vibe that's floating around
you've got
guys who you know whit martindale with
the the kenny powers mullet uh
you you've got a different kind of a
character sure that some
owners may not be comfortable saying
here are the keys
please try to drive it safely i i think
that's again a very fair assessment
they're not
not necessarily always the guys that are
the most
buttoned up like ceo and stand in front
of the the podium and
and the emblem of the team behind you
like yeah okay maybe they might not
win that aspect of being a head coach as
compared to others but
but i i think at the end of the day you
know it is about your coaching ability
and i do think that owners need to get
over that a little bit
i i mean i know we want young offensive
guys and all that and we're talking
about brian dabal and the chargers okay
it makes sense there
but i still think like in the big grand
scheme of things
owners right now are dropping the ball
on some of those type of guys
wink martindale salah dan campbell
you know down with the new orleans
saints guys that
yeah okay they don't look like you know
johnny ceo
but they can coach a team and i don't
know what i mean
tell me about mike vrabel how's that
working out in tennessee oh
pretty good curmudgeon you know doesn't
have that you know ceo look
uh so so uh yeah yeah but he's already
lost matt lafleur and he could lose
but your point about that is very real
you're right that point is very real no
doubt about it
yeah uh and back to jason garrett and
look i i
i it you're right cowboys fans
actually missed him this year that's how
bad it was
for the cowboys early in the season in
pretty much
every cowboys game at some point jason
garrett's name would be trending because
cowboys fans were pining
for jason garrett but there were flaws
there early in his time with the team
there was the issue of can he call plays
while he's also managing the game as a
coach
right and he couldn't so eventually they
took that away
and then there was the notorious icing
of his own kicker if you remember that i
think it was in a game against the
cardinals
and that just kind of settled in it was
he was a guy who
was on the way up and reached the
plateau
and never really moved from there sure
and i i i don't think all due respect i
don't think that's what the chargers
need it could work
not saying it won't but when you had
tony romo
and you had all the spending power that
jerry jones brings to the table
and you have the glitz and the glamour
of america's team and he did a great job
coexisting with some really strong
personalities that's right
i just don't i just don't think that is
the formula
right now with the charge you don't have
a lot of strong personalities running
that team
you need somebody who's going to come in
and kickstart a team that has been
second-class citizen to the rams ever
since they both ended up back in la
and i think you you need somebody who's
more dynamic you need somebody as
dynamic
as sean mcvay if not more dynamic than
sean mcvay
to really close that gap because i think
the chargers have the better roster
right now than the rams
but they clearly don't have the better
coach yeah i mean i'm with you
it's right there you're right it's it's
not far off i mean if the rams out do
have a better roster it's by very little
um you know i i understand like the
optics around jason garrett
uh i look at him as a little bit more
you know in a little bit more of a
positive way
i think than most people and listen i
know i'm biased too yeah i know him i
played with him in tampa bay
i'm sure but i think it goes back a
little bit to like what you said earlier
it's what are you looking for and he can
be that ceo
type of guy you just mentioned all the
things he had to deal with in dallas how
well he did
managing that situation you know you
talked about the chargers and
you know the injuries and the issues
like that that's what that kind of head
coach does he gets everybody in the
organization on the same page what's the
deal why are we getting so hurt so much
what are we going to do to fix this how
are we going to change it blah blah blah
i don't just coach football
i'm going to get into all aspects i
think that's where
the beauty of jason garrett is let alone
hey took over tony romo at a fairly
young age did what he did with dak
prescott
i'm sure that's the appeal there but i i
hear what you're saying
it's not sexy it's not going to get the
la chargers fan base going oh my gosh
here we go this is going like
you know everything we dreamed of no
it's not it's it would be a different
approach altogether
and yeah i'm with you i kind of want the
let's go for the high-flying offensive
guy
and go for it and that's where i like
brian dabal
we need to move on to the jaguars but
one thing i want to say for now
and we may have to find some space to
develop this because i think it's going
to take some time to really break it i
think it's going to take some time to
really break it down
because i think he'd be perfect for this
chargers job sure
frankly to if to the extent that the
chargers need a top to bottom
reevaluation of everything they're doing
now it may take several years to get to
where they need to be but justin herbert
is the guy around whom you build for the
next 10 years so it would make sense
and if i were josh mcdaniels i'd be very
interested i just don't know that teams
are going to be interested
in daniel's after what happened with the
colts a few years ago all right
oh well don't forget to last year he you
know there was a lot of play and we
heard
you and i heard a lot of rumors about
him with the new york giants right
the carolina panthers thing that
happened there a little bit there was
certainly names circulating
but yeah last year wasn't a great
offensive year with brady there
the patriots and then of course this
year wasn't you know great either we
know that so
it's a what have you done for me lately
type of thing and yeah
he might be stuck in a spot here now
where he might have to wait for a new
quarterback or whatever that is and wait
for the offense to explode again before
he ever becomes the hot name
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports